et on poursuit cette page cinéma avec
vous mais quel est le midoro bonsoir
vous allez nous parler des films à ne
pas manquer en 2023 et on va tout de
suite commencer par un film qui vient
qui vient de sortir en salle ce mercredi
4 janvier son nom tirailleur dans le
rôle principal on retrouve le trappiste
de 44 ans Omar Sy le synopsis en 1917
Bakary Diallo s'enroule dans l'armée
française pour rejoindre son fils de 17
ans recruté pour participer à la
première guerre mondiale envoyé sur le
front père et fils vont affronter la
guerre ensemble avec des objectifs
différents une belle histoire de famille
avec Antoine de fond une page historique
on regarde un extrait
incorporer africain du haut Niger du
Sénégal de la Guinée du Soudan vous
allez contribuer à cette éclatante
victoire
[Musique]
vous ne serez plus des indigènes vous
serez des Français
et il aura également un film Marvel à ne
pas manquer cette année Michael oui je
vais pas vous mentir je l'attends avec
impatience c'est ant Man 3 ou Ant-Man et
la guêpe quand tu Mania la sortie prévue
le 15 février prochain le film racontera
toujours l'histoire de Scotland et
obvandin le duo va explorer la dimension
subatomique sur le royaume quantique et
ses mystères ils vont aussi devoir faire
face à l'un des plus dangereux individus
du multivers kangle conquérant c'est
pour cela que le film est très attendu
par les fans de Marvel on le regarde un
extrait
c'est quoi cet endroit
c'est un univers caché à l'intérieur du
nôtre
de quoi tu as peur
je ne vous ai pas tout dit et on
continue avec un film plutôt grand
public si je vous dis un village
d'irréductible Gaulois résiste encore et
toujours à l'envahisseur vous me prenez
quoi Mathilde
Astérix et Obélix et bien oui Astérix et
Obélix l'Empire du Milieu va sortir le
premier février prochain dans les
acteurs on retrouvera à Guillaume Canet
originaire de plaisir Gilles Lellouche
l'ancien l'attaquant du PSG Zlatan
Ibrahimovic ou encore Vincent Cassel
l'histoire se déroulera en 50 avant
Jésus-Christ l'impératrice de Chine est
emprisonné suite à un coup d'état sa
fille demande de l'aide Astérix et
Obélix qui accepte les Romains seront
également de la partie avec César et ça
puissante armé ça donne très envie
d'aller le voir votre quatrième choix
Michael se porte sur le film Barbie je
sais que vous l'attendez avec impatience
un Mathilde intitulé Barbie le film
réalisé par Greta garwin sortir en
juillet 2023 le long métrage racontera
l'histoire de la fameuse poupée elle
vient d'être expulsée de barbiland et se
retrouve dans le monde humain pour
chercher le vrai bonheur Barbie sera
joué par Margot Robbie il y aura
également Ryan Gosling dedans on regarde
un extrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
effectivement un film bien déjanté que
j'ai bien envie d'aller voir au cinéma
et enfin on termine par un film qui
sortira en février Michael oui le 22
février très précisément the Fabel man
sera réalisé par Steven Spielberg
racontera l'histoire du jeune Samy
fabelman qui rêve de devenir réalisateur
c'est un biopic de 2h30 ce qui est
intéressant c'est que cette
autobiographie s'inspire de la propre
jeunesse du cinéaste un projet très
personnel pour Steven Spielberg qu'il
avait en tête depuis de nombreuses
années le film a fait un carton en
avant-première au festival international
du film de Toronto 2022 où il a remporté
le prix du public et pour les puristes
de musique de film c'est John Williams
qui a travaillé sur le projet merci
beaucoup Mickaël Midor est-ce que autour
du plateau Mickaël Régine vous avez une
préférence pour l'un de ses films ou
est-ce que un autre film pour vous c'est
le film de l'année 2023
j'ai vraiment tous envie de les voir
peut-être Ant-Man un peu moins que les
autres vous n'êtes pas trop Marvel oh
non pas trop mais sinon oui c'est vrai
que tous les autres tirailleurs je pense
que c'est intéressant de de se pencher
dessus Barbie pour mon enfant
Astérix et Obélix pareil et Spielberg
ouais enfin ouais je suis très
intéressée
[Musique]
ont l'air très très bien j'irai voir
aussi c'est open Heimer c'est avec
l'acteur de de Peaky blinders c'est sur
comment était créé la bombe atomique en
fait pendant pendant la guerre froide
donc c'est un film un peu historique que
j'aimerais bien découvrir également de
beaux films en tout cas en 2023
découvrir au cinéma